Lucia:你们坐车过来的话是不是有点远
Lucia: Was it a bit far for you guys to come by car?
Alice:不太远呀
Alice: Not really.
Alice:嗨呀你是怎么来的
Alice: By the way, how did you get here?
Lucia:我走过来的
Lucia: I walked over.
Lucia:就是从咱们那走到那个
Lucia: Just walked from our place to that...
Lucia:就是那个
Lucia: You know, that...
Lucia:那算什么呀
Lucia: What’s it called?
Lucia:卫生所挺好挺近的其实
Lucia: The clinic is actually quite close.
Lucia:就是
Lucia: So...
Alice:可能可能走车的话就是有点点绕
Alice: Maybe if you took a car, it would be a bit roundabout.
Lucia:对对因为可能小路车没法过就只能人行
Lucia: Yeah, because the small roads are only for walking.
Lucia:我是那个啥
Lucia: I mean...
Lucia:咱们
Lucia: We...
Lucia:吃完饭之后
Lucia: After dinner,
Lucia:就我给我问了一下我们家人
Lucia: I asked my family,
Lucia:觉得有没有必要
Lucia: If it was necessary...
Lucia:打一下我妈是他朋友养的猫就是那个
Lucia: Because my mom's friend's cat...
Lucia:他他朋友养的猫就有就是给猫打过疫苗了
Lucia: Her friend's cat had been vaccinated.
Lucia:猫抓到之后也就去打了这个疫苗了
Lucia: After the cat scratched me, I went to get the vaccine.
Lucia:然后他说觉得还是打下比较放心
Lucia: They said it’s better to be safe and get the shot.
Lucia:尤其这个不是自己自己家养的
Lucia: Especially since this one isn’t raised at home.
Lucia:尤其还是别人家养的
Lucia: It's someone else's pet
Lucia:然后我就想着我就去一下吧
Lucia: So I thought I'd just go and check
Lucia:然后我就出门
Lucia: And then I headed out
Lucia:我先去了咖啡馆然后问了一下之后
Lucia: I first went to the café and asked around
Lucia:然后那个到了那条路再接着往前走
Lucia: Then I walked down that road and kept going
Lucia:再拐一下
Lucia: Took another turn
Lucia:然后再拐一下就到那个卫生所了
Lucia: And then another turn to get to the clinic
Lucia:我本来还想着应该挺快
Lucia: I thought it would be pretty quick
Lucia:然后我刚好就趁这个时间打完回去
Lucia: And I could just get it done and head back in time
Lucia:大家可以开始录
Lucia: You guys can start recording
Lucia:结果他稍微慢一点点
Lucia: But it took a bit longer
Lucia:因为
Lucia: Because
Lucia:sorrysorry
Lucia: Sorry, sorry
Lucia:sorry sorry
Alice:你敲门的时候我以为是第二早上
Alice: When you knocked, I thought it was the next morning
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈第二早上
Lucia: Hahahaha, the next morning
Alice:都今周六了
Alice: It's already Saturday
Lucia:一觉睡到第二天
Lucia: Slept all the way to the next day
Alice:我今天晚上巨困
Alice: I am super tired tonight.
Lucia:我也好困
Lucia: I'm really tired too.
Alice:我昨天烧烤我太废力气了我感觉我
Alice: I was so exhausted from the barbecue yesterday, I feel like I...
Alice:一下被榨干了
Alice: ...was completely drained.
Lucia:我知道这个车走的是哪条道
Lucia: I know which route this car is taking.
Lucia:我刚在高德地图上
Lucia: I just checked on Gaode map.
Lucia:看那个位置的时候
Lucia: When I looked at the location...
Lucia:我大概知道这个路线
Lucia: ...I roughly figured out this route.
Lucia:哎还得还是得自己查地图
Lucia: Ah, still need to check the map myself.
Lucia:我前几天根本就不认路
Lucia: A few days ago, I didn't know the roads at all.
Lucia:今天一查之后我觉得我已经对这片的
Lucia: After checking today, I think I...
Lucia:大概方位蒙清了
Lucia: ...have a rough idea of the direction in this area.
Alice:几只狗狗在这里玩
Alice: A few dogs are playing here.
Lucia:我现在有点PTSD了
Lucia: I feel a bit of PTSD now.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia:啊没事
Lucia: Ah, it's okay.
Lucia:我在想后面的一个
Lucia: I was thinking about the next one.
Alice:有什么可以帮你的
Alice: Is there anything I can help you with?
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:不是特别那个啥
Lucia: Not really a big deal.
Alice:哎呦电死我了
Alice: Ouch, it shocked me!
Alice:谢彬竹你那个彬是三点水那个彬吗
Alice: Xie Binzhu, is your "Bin" the one with three water radicals?
Alice:竹子的竹
Alice: And "Zhu" as in bamboo?
Alice:这有什么含义吗
Alice: Does it have any special meaning?
Alice:哦确实
Alice: Oh, indeed.
Lucia:哎哇
Lucia: Oh wow.
Alice:看这个名字我就在想这个水木属性
Alice: Seeing this name, I was thinking about the elements of water and wood.
Lucia:我之前还以为你是两点水的那个冰
Lucia: I used to think it was the "Bin" with two water radicals.
Alice:那你是不是起名的时候给你算过呀
Alice: Did you get your name calculated when you were named?
Lucia:三几几
Lucia: Three something something.
Lucia:哈哈几几几
Lucia: Haha something something something.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:至少我也得记住三个数是吧
Lucia: At least I need to remember three numbers, right?
Alice:缺水缺木
Alice: Lacking water and wood.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:需要一点点点点帮助
Alice: Need a little bit of help.
Alice:木生火 火生土
Alice: Wood generates fire, fire generates earth.
Alice:土生金
Alice: Earth generates metal.
Alice:那那个手链是不是也是按这个选的呀
Alice: So is that bracelet chosen based on this too?
Alice:就选黑色的
Alice: Choosing the black one?
Alice:但是黑色确实是补水的
Alice: But black really does hydrate.
Lucia:他只能等待他找你哈
Lucia: He can only wait for him to find you, huh.
Lucia:那要不手机静音
Lucia: How about putting your phone on silent?
Lucia:我有时候手机静音自己没发现
Lucia: Sometimes I put my phone on silent and don't realize.
Alice:我一直手机在静音谁都别想
Alice: My phone is always on silent, nobody can reach me.
Lucia:谁都别想找到你
Lucia: Nobody can reach you.
Lucia:那快递小哥给你送快递的时候呢
Lucia: What about when the delivery guy brings your packages?
Alice:一般我又不送货上门
Alice: Usually I don't do home delivery.
Alice:都是到驿站之类的
Alice: They go to a pick-up station or something.
Lucia:晚上还怪冷的
Lucia: It's still pretty cold at night.
Lucia:我甚至还穿了一个厚外套
Lucia: I'm even wearing a thick coat.
Alice:直接开门
Alice: Just open the door.
Lucia:看我说的完全正确吧
Lucia: See, I was totally right.
Lucia:三几几几几几哈哈哈
Lucia: Three something something hahaha.
Lucia:哎他们都在干啥
Lucia: Hey, what are they doing?
Lucia:都在二楼哎
Lucia: They're all on the second floor.
Lucia:我说这直接一按就开了
Lucia: I told you, just press and it opens.
Jake:哎呀回来啦
Jake: Hey, you're back!
Lucia:啊呀晚上好
Lucia: Ah, good evening!
Alice:你进来了吗
Alice: Did you come in?
Alice:要上楼吗
Alice: Are you coming upstairs?
Jake:上吧
Jake: Yeah, let's go.
Alice:上吧
Alice: Let's go.
Jake:外面下雨了吗
Jake: Is it raining outside?
Nicous: 没下呢
Nicous: No, it's not.
Lucia:没下呢
Lucia: No, it's not.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay then.
Alice:这是干嘛
Alice: What's this about?
Jake:来坐
Jake: Come have a seat.
Jake:大伙现在在讨论
Jake: Everyone's discussing it right now.
Jake:哎最后一天唱点啥
Jake: Hey, what to sing on the last day.
Jake:这咱就不跳舞了
Jake: We're not going to dance.
Katrina: 你们的朋友会唱歌吗
Katrina: Do your friends sing?
Lucia:卡拉OK的唱法吗
Lucia: Like karaoke singing?
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:就就就这种唱法
Jake: Yeah, just like that.
Lucia:不会弹吉他
Lucia: Can't play guitar.
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina: 不用不用唱
Katrina: No need to sing.
Katrina: 到时候反正他有音响
Katrina: He'll have the sound system ready anyway.
Katrina: 直接那个呗
Katrina: Just go with that.
Katrina: 唱歌就搞个话筒
Katrina: For singing, just get a microphone.
Jake:还有话筒
Jake: There's also a microphone.
Katrina: 然后唱歌也可以获得获得
Katrina: And singing can also earn you...
Alice:可以坐这
Alice: You can sit here.
Alice:我会骑牛
Alice: I can ride a bull.
Alice:正威的唱法
Alice: The proper singing style.
Shure: 蛋黄的长裙
Shure: Egg yolk yellow dress.
Shure: 蓬松的头发
Shure: Fluffy hair.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Lucia:我们不是合唱吗
Lucia: Aren't we doing a chorus?
Katrina: 是合唱所以在挑两首歌
Katrina: Yes, a chorus, so we're picking two songs.
Katrina: 一首就开场欢快一点
Katrina: One for a lively start.
Katrina: 一首就是适合晚上的慢悠悠的那种
Katrina: And one that's slow and suitable for the evening.
Katrina: 开场的话有听这个
Katrina: For the start, have you heard this?
Katrina: 开心超人你听过吗
Katrina: Happy Superman, have you heard it?
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Shure: 结尾想好
Shure: Think about the ending.
Jake:哈哈哈可拉倒吧
Jake: Haha, forget it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 可以整的
Shure: We can pull it off.
Jake:插点电插点电
Jake: Plug it in, plug it in.
Shure: 给我来一个宝
Shure: Give me a charger.
Lucia:我需要一个充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Shure: 给我来个宝
Shure: Give me a charger.
Shure: 这首歌叫啥来着
Shure: What's this song called again?
Tasha:好像就叫朋友吧
Tasha: I think it's just called "Friend."
Shure: 啊老男孩
Shure: Ah, "Old Boy."
Tasha:啊对不起
Tasha: Oh, sorry.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 还没唱难忘今宵呢
Katrina: We haven't sung "Unforgettable Tonight" yet.
Katrina: 难忘今宵哎
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight," hey.
Katrina: 我觉得可以
Katrina: I think it's good.
Nicous: 这个好
Nicous: This is good.
Katrina: 我们还可以采取春晚的那种
Katrina: We can also do it like the Spring Festival Gala.
Lucia:每人唱一句
Lucia: Everyone sings a line.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
修厦:上春山是吧
Shure: Like the Spring Gala, right?
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: Then...
Lucia:再大合唱了
Lucia: Then a big chorus.
Katrina: 也行也行
Katrina: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 每人唱一句工作量就小一点
Katrina: If everyone sings one line, the workload will be smaller.
Alice:我有了
Alice: I got it.
Lucia:17
Lucia: 17.
Jake:17没事多很多
Jake: 17 is fine, plenty more.
Lucia:行 我信你
Lucia: Okay, I trust you.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:那给你一个
Jake: Then here's one for you.
Lucia:没事没事不开玩笑
Lucia: No worries, just kidding.
Jake:那我给你三个
Jake: Then I'll give you three.
Lucia:行行行用完了我随时换
Lucia: Okay, okay, I'll swap them out as needed.
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 对但你可以拿双筷子吗
Katrina: Yeah, but can you get a pair of chopsticks?
Tasha:筷子呢
Tasha: Where are the chopsticks?
Shure: 哦我需要个宝
Shure: Oh, I need a treasure.
Jake:你给你一个宝
Jake: Here, take a treasure.
Shure: 谢谢宝
Shure: Thanks, treasure.
Katrina: 海遇恋好像是那个谁的
Katrina: "Haiyu Lian," seems like it's by someone.
Katrina: 很老的一首歌
Katrina: It's a very old song.
Katrina: 你们有推荐的吗
Katrina: Do you have any recommendations?
Katrina: 就是开头比较欢快的
Katrina: Something with a cheerful opening.
Katrina: 你把那几个弹给他们听一遍呗
Katrina: Play those few songs for them to hear.
Katrina: 开心超人
Katrina: "Happy Superman."
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone.
Shure: 听过开心超人吗
Shure: Have you heard of "Happy Superman"?
Lucia:no
Lucia: No.
Lucia:那个再见吧妈妈吗
Lucia: Is it "Goodbye, Mom"?
Shure: 什么是快乐星球
Shure: What's the "Happy Planet"?
Lucia:就是那个
Lucia: It's that one.
Katrina: 开心超人弹
Katrina: Play "Happy Superman."
Jake:每人拧一个
Jake: Everyone take one.
Lucia:我洗个手
Lucia: I'm going to wash my hands.
Lucia:我刚从那个啥医院回来
Lucia: I just came back from that hospital.
Lucia:不敢直接接触吃的
Lucia: I'm afraid to touch the food directly.
Katrina: 尝尝
Katrina: Try it.
Katrina: 你这是开心超人的歌吗
Katrina: Is this the song of "Happy Superman"?
Shure: 阿里嘎多
Shure: Arigato.
Shure: 啊是的
Shure: Yes, it is.
Katrina: 怎么缠着悲悲伤的感觉
Katrina: Why does it feel sad though?
Shure: 我可以把
Shure: I can...
Katrina: 哎哎要怎么吃
Katrina: Hey hey, how do we eat this?
Alice:轩
Alice: Xuan...
Katrina: 嗯轩啊
Katrina: Yeah, Xuan...
Alice:轩啊
Alice: Xuan...
Shure: 轩哈哈
Shure: Xuan, haha...
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What's this?
Jake:嗯来了来了来
Jake: Yeah, here, here, come on.
Lucia:谢谢嗯嗯
Lucia: Thanks, uh-huh.
Lucia:年糕吗
Lucia: Is this rice cake?
Alice:麻薯
Alice: It's mochi.
Jake:看看这个店
Jake: Look at this place.
Lucia:这两个是什么味
Lucia: What flavors are these two?
Tasha:豆乳的和可可的
Tasha: Soybean and cocoa.
Lucia:啊谢谢吃一个
Lucia: Ah, thanks. I'll try one.
Katrina: 他0.5倍速
Katrina: He’s at 0.5 speed.
Lucia:可以蘸着吗
Lucia: Can I dip it?
Tasha:要多蘸
Tasha: Dip more.
Lucia:碗都要给我蘸走了
Lucia: I'm going to dip the whole bowl!
Katrina: 开心往前飞
Katrina: Happy, flying forward.
Katrina: 快点
Katrina: Hurry up.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia:我是不是跟奶油有什么仇啊
Lucia: Do I have a grudge against cream or something?
Shure: 多少多少学费
Shure: How much, how much is the tuition?
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: Huh, what?
Shure: 最重要
Shure: The most important...
Tasha:什么不要学费
Tasha: What? No tuition.
Lucia:我感觉我又该洗裤子了
Lucia: I feel like I need to wash my pants again.
Lucia:我好像跟奶油有仇似的
Lucia: I seem to have a grudge against cream.
Tasha:好那给我二成
Tasha: Alright, then give me twenty percent.
Tasha:分成吧我亲力教教学
Tasha: Let’s split it. I’ll personally teach.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Lucia:有你去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: If you go where there are many Chinese students, there definitely will be.
Tasha:他说有没有竞争力
Tasha: He’s asking if there’s competition.
Lucia:有竞争力啊
Lucia: There’s competition.
Lucia:就是去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: But if you go where there are many Chinese students, there definitely will be.
Tasha:那不是有市场吗
Tasha: Then isn't there a market?
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Tasha:不是我的意思是啊
Tasha: No, what I mean is...
Jake:这也没多少
Jake: This isn't much.
Tasha:利润很大
Tasha: The profit is huge.
Lucia:我先放一下
Lucia: I'll put this here first.
Tasha:去办一个
Tasha: Go get one.
Lucia:拿瓶水
Lucia: Grab a bottle of water.
Tasha:开家店
Tasha: Open a store.
Lucia:这水应该可以喝吧
Lucia: This water should be drinkable, right?
Lucia:我刚看了
Lucia: I just checked.
Lucia:医生让我多喝点水哦
Lucia: The doctor told me to drink more water.
Lucia:我想申请一下这疫苗能报销吗
Lucia: I want to apply for reimbursement for this vaccine.
Jake:呃能报能报
Jake: Uh, it can be reimbursed.
Lucia:好谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks, thanks.
Lucia:能算工伤吗
Lucia: Can it be considered a work injury?
Lucia:我甚至期待项目结束还得再打两针
Lucia: I'm even expecting to get two more shots after the project ends.
Jake:啊行行
Jake: Ah, sure, sure.
Tasha:没有去新疆学啊
Tasha: Didn't you go to Xinjiang to learn?
Tasha:不是这个不是在哪里学
Tasha: No, this isn't something you learn somewhere.
Tasha:这个没有在哪学
Tasha: This isn't learned anywhere.
Shure: 这不是假的吗
Shure: Isn't this fake?
Shure: 哎呦你这不听
Shure: Oh, you don't listen.
Lucia:万一我今天晚上发烧了的话
Lucia: What if I get a fever tonight?
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Hahaha, okay.
Jake:好待会可以
Jake: Okay, maybe later.
Lucia:请大家那个
Lucia: Everyone, please...
Tasha:会发烧的
Tasha: You will get a fever.
Lucia:帮我冻点冰水哈哈哈
Lucia: Help me freeze some ice water, hahaha.
Lucia:没有没有应该不会就
Lucia: No, no, it shouldn't happen...
Tasha:那不是假的吗
Tasha: Isn't that fake?
Jake:看看你你伤
Jake: Look at you, you're hurt.
Lucia:这就到现在还在红中
Lucia: It's still red even now.
Lucia:看这和这个地方
Lucia: Look at this spot.
Lucia:对现在好像又比我下午好一点了
Lucia: Yeah, now it seems a bit better than this afternoon.
Lucia:就我特还有点
Lucia: I still feel a bit...
Lucia:就我确实还有点红然后
Lucia: I still feel a bit red here and...
Jake:应该还行问题不大
Jake: It should be fine, not a big problem.
Lucia:对理论上应该问题不大但是
Lucia: Yeah, theoretically, it shouldn't be a big problem, but...
Jake:多打几针几挺好
Jake: Getting a few more shots is good.
Lucia:规定是必须要至少要打4次或者5针
Lucia: The rule is you have to get at least 4 or 5 shots.
Lucia:然后最少最少要打4针
Lucia: And at least, you need to get 4 shots.
Lucia:就是打5针
Lucia: Actually, it's 5 shots.
Lucia:就是28天
Lucia: That's 28 days.
Lucia:然后隔多久
Lucia: So, how long between shots?
Lucia:隔一星期打一针
Lucia: One shot every week.
Lucia:如果是打4针就是今天要打两针
Lucia: If it's 4 shots, then you need two today.
Lucia:对所以我两边都打了一针
Lucia: Yeah, so I got one on each side today.
Jake:我以前也被猫抓了
Jake: I got scratched by a cat before.
Jake:然后我我我是我是在美国住一个LMB
Jake: I was staying at an Airbnb in the US.
Jake:然后被那边有一只猫抓了
Jake: And a cat there scratched me.
Jake:然后抓了就
Jake: So, after it scratched me...
Jake:我和房东房东说打过哦
Jake: I told the landlord, and they said it was vaccinated.
Jake:然后我我我我也就是
Jake: At first, I was really scared, but I got over it.
Jake:虽然第一天很慌但是后来也不管了
Jake: Even though I was panicking on the first day, I just let it go later.
Lucia:对我今天还专门去咖啡馆问了
Lucia: Yeah, I even went to the café today to ask.
Lucia:我说这这小狗有没有疫苗本
Lucia: I asked if the puppy had its vaccination records.
Lucia:然后他们说就是就是
Lucia: And they said, well...
Lucia:这个狗现在的疫苗他们还没带去打
Lucia: They haven't taken the puppy to get vaccinated yet.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍说打过
Lucia: But the shelter said it has been vaccinated.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍没有给他们给疫苗本
Lucia: But the shelter didn't give them the vaccination records.
Lucia:然后我觉得啊那要不然回去打一下吧
Lucia: I think maybe we should go back and get the shot.
Lucia:对不对
Lucia: Right?
Lucia:所以我就
Lucia: So I...
Lucia:然后我问了一下我我那个我家人
Lucia: Then I asked my family about it.
Lucia:我妈说他朋友养猫
Lucia: My mom said her friend has a cat.
Lucia:然后被自己家猫抓了
Lucia: And got scratched by their own cat.
Lucia:就也去打了
Lucia: They also went to get a shot.
Lucia:我说算了算了还是去打一个吧
Lucia: So I said, forget it, I should go get one too.
Lucia:然后我本来想着对
Lucia: I originally thought...
Lucia:就是我可能很快就打回来了啊
Lucia: I might just quickly get the shot and be back.
Jake:那种大长狗
Jake: Those big dogs...
Jake:那小狗没听就没听见
Jake: The little ones didn't even hear it.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 我说如果没有打疫苗得上狂犬病会怎么样
Tasha: I said, what happens if you don't get vaccinated and get rabies?
Lucia:我们打算开始之前打算回来了
Lucia: We planned to come back before we started.
Tasha: 马上死掉
Tasha: You die immediately.
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Because it's actually pretty close.
Lucia:对但是那个因为他那是值班嘛
Lucia: Yeah, but since they were on duty...
Lucia:然后所以我就要等一下
Lucia: I had to wait a bit.
Lucia:那个医生
Lucia: For the doctor.
Lucia:然后我还要再咨询一下他是怎么回事
Lucia: Then I still need to ask him what's going on.
Shure: 大家有看到我的手机吗
Shure: Has anyone seen my phone?
Lucia:然后怎么打
Lucia: And how to make the call?
Lucia:然后所以就稍微晚了一点
Lucia: So, I was a bit late.
Jake:打个电话
Jake: Make a call.
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri.
Jake:那个电话
Jake: That call.
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri.
Katrina: 你那疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is your vaccine per shot?
Shure: 在我的iPhone上播放声音算是
Shure: Play sound on my iPhone.
Lucia:基本上算是100块钱一针
Lucia: It's basically 100 yuan per shot.
Katrina: 哦那还很便宜
Katrina: Oh, that's quite cheap.
Lucia:对但是要打五针或者四针
Lucia: Yeah, but you need to get five or four shots.
Lucia:就是打四针的话
Lucia: So, if you get four shots...
Lucia:你就是第一天打的时候要打两针
Lucia: On the first day, you need to get two shots.
Lucia:左右胳膊上各一针
Lucia: One on each arm.
Alice:这个疫苗价钱还不一样的吗
Alice: Are the vaccine prices different?
Shure: 导航啊
Shure: Navigate.
Lucia:对还有300的哦
Lucia: Yes, there are also 300 yuan ones.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia:但我觉得310只有点太夸张了
Lucia: But I think 310 is a bit too much.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:而且就是
Lucia: And also...
Shure: 你要把所有的全住了
Shure: You have to stay for all of them.
Katrina: 他们的功能不都是抑制吗
Katrina: Aren't they all for suppression?
Katrina: 难道还有什么抑制得快一点
Katrina: Is there one that suppresses faster?
Lucia:好像没啥区别
Lucia: Seems like there's no difference.
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia:应该是没啥区别
Lucia: There shouldn't be any difference.
Alice:他是根据什么来给你选针的呀
Alice: How do they decide which shot to give you?
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:这100多跟300多有什么区别啊
Alice: What's the difference between the 100 and 300 yuan ones?
Lucia:不知道啊
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia:咱也不知道啊
Lucia: We don't know.
Alice:我们之前打了
Alice: We got...
Alice:就打完一一个就快2,000
Alice: Each shot cost almost 2,000 yuan.
Katrina: 定歌定歌定歌定歌定歌
Katrina: Ding ding ding ding ding.
Lucia:哦那你可能那
Lucia: Oh, maybe that...
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Because that place is actually quite close.
Lucia:那你那那就是你说的这种可能是300一针的
Lucia: So you're saying it could be 300 per shot?
Shure: 定歌快快定完歌
Shure: Pick a song quickly, hurry up.
Katrina: 定完歌睡觉了
Katrina: Pick a song and then sleep.
Lucia:如果300多就打完了就是1500对吧
Lucia: If it's more than 300, it would be 1500, right?
Shure: 我睡觉觉
Shure: I'm going to sleep.
Alice:那个好像三针
Alice: That one seems to be three shots.
Katrina: 定完歌写论文哎
Katrina: Pick a song and then write the paper.
Lucia:三针
Lucia: Three shots.
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Alice:反正我妈去打的
Alice: Anyway, my mom went to get it.
Katrina: 他们要严逼了
Katrina: They are going to be strict.
Lucia:我妈他朋友打的就
Lucia: My mom's friend got it too.
Lucia:也是100块钱一针的
Lucia: It was also 100 per shot.
Lucia:然后我觉得这应该就可以了
Lucia: So I think this should be fine.
Jake:OKOKOKOK
Jake: OK OK OK OK
Katrina: 要不听一下这歌
Katrina: How about we listen to this song?
Katrina: 这应该合唱出来会好听
Katrina: This should sound good as a duet.
Lucia:希望我今天晚上不要发烧
Lucia: Hopefully I don't get a fever tonight.
Lucia:医生说常见的副作用是可能会发烧
Lucia: The doctor said a common side effect is a fever.
Jake:哦就是打疫苗发烧
Jake: Oh, getting a fever from the vaccine.
Lucia:对打疫苗发烧对
Lucia: Yes, getting a fever from the vaccine.
Shure: 来先听一下下歌
Shure: Let's listen to the song first.
Shure: 听一下歌
Shure: Listen to the song.
Shure: 这首歌大家听过吗
Shure: Has everyone heard this song?